il y a eu énormément de travail pour
arriver jusqu'à aujourd'hui un an après
la fin de l'enquête publique sur la
crise qui a frappé le CHSD et RN Québec
annonce que 5 CHSLD privé ont réussi à
se convertir en centre d'hébergement
conventionné il recevront 20 millions de
dollars du gouvernement par année et
nourrissent dans les grands gardiens de
tout ce processus de conventionnement
d'abord on le fait pour qui on le fait
pour les résidents pour s'assurer
d'avoir une qualité des soins services
qui est similaires d'un établissement à
l'autre on décida le conventionnement
des CHS et le des
privé demandation de la coronaire j'ai
un camel pour ne plus jamais revivre la
tragédie du printemps 2020
pendant la première vague de la covid 19
près de 4000 aînés sont morts dans les
centres de soins et de longue durée
ce propriétaire d'un CHSLD nouvellement
conventionné sans désormais qu'il a un
fardeau de moins sur ses épaules les
exigences
[Musique]
beaucoup plus adaptée donc les coûts
minimal
augmenter de façon astronomique
il n'en est qu'à 8 Québec repousse donc
son échéancier d'un an le
conventionnement des CHSLD privé ça va
beaucoup trop lentement au Québec on est
complètement à côté de la cible donc on
devra accélérer le pas et être
transparent mais autant dans le public
que dans le privé une qualité des soins
est encore loin d'être exemplaire selon
certains est-ce qu'on veut vraiment
mettre le privé à la hauteur de ce qui
se fait présentement comme ça dans les
CHSLD public non on va rendre publics
les privés alors que le public lui-même
de gros travaux de grands devoirs à
faire à terme Québec promet de
conventionner les 40 CHSLD privés de la
province d'ici 2026 mais la ministre
responsable des Aînés espère être
capable d'y arriver avant d'ailleurs
selon elle dans les prochaines semaines
d'autres ententes avec les CHSLD privé
pour être conclu ici Charles Dumoulin
Radio-Canada Montréal